and today we're going to be talking
about career transitions
changing jobs and deciding what is next
so i know a lot of you might be on the
job hunt so we'd like to kind of
get a feel for where you are we'll tell
you a little bit about us
and we're going to talk a lot about
getting ready for a transition and then
how to execute that transition
first just a little bit about me if you
haven't if we haven't met yet i'm angela
mcdonald i am one of the
career coaches at udacity i'm also a
corporate trainer i have a background in
finance consulting
lived overseas for a long time in
australia china and singapore
and i've also created a program called
up next which is a career transition
program
that we're going to talk about today i
created that
with diane and we will be giving a
special offer for udacity students today
also we have diane cabal she is our
special guest here today
she's a talent alignment consultant she
helps individuals and organizations grow
their talent
and has been working in for over 20
years in talent
development she has created something
called creating
career essentials and essential circles
essential circles is something you all
might be interested in again we'll be
showing you some offers today
it helps people identify their natural
gifts and talents
so they can get ready for the next step
in their career
we'll be talking about some of the
pitfalls that people fall in
as we go through transitions and a lot
of that is sometimes
setting the foundation knowing what
we're going after
and knowing how then to make that happen
so let's get an idea real quick here of
where people are who who are on today
if you can let us know if you are an
alumni
a current student or both if you have
the annotation tools at the top you
could just give us
a star up there and tell me are you an
alumni
a current student or both so you can
click on the star give us a stamp or you
can just type in the chat
so we've got several students several
alumni
several students alumni alumni so
then it looks like we have quite a
combination several people popping in
that they are both an alumni and a
student i know that's
always so impressive not only finishing
that first nanodegree but
um the next one and the next one beyond
that so it's fantastic
yeah ambitious group here huh absolutely
wonderful so it looks like we have a
nice variety perfect
all right
and now that we know kind of where you
are as a student
or alumni let us
know in the poll that's going to pop up
here what describes your current
situation
if you should see the polling pop up i
am employed and i
love my job or like my job very content
i am employed but i want to find a new
job
i am unemployed and know the type of job
i want to find
or i'm unemployed and i'm not quite sure
what job i should be looking for
again this is anonymous it's just to
give us an idea of
kind of who's on and make sure we target
our conversation to all of you
and help you go through the some of the
nobody's employed and likes their job
i guess those are employed that really
love their job they're not on today
yeah i guess that's right
so we'll give you a couple more seconds
so we've got it looks like and i'll and
i'll show you all the pulling that we
have here so you can see where we are
but it looks like we've got we've got a
pretty
equal spread between people who are
employed and want to find a new job
unemployed and they know what they want
to do or they're unemployed and they're
not quite sure
so i think there's it's very common to
be in
every one of those steps at some point
right in our
careers so it's it's good to identify
that and it helps us as we go through
the next
hour or so to talk about
what to do in those different situations
and think about the transition and the
change that we all need to go through
sometimes
so i'd like to show a few quotes
that i think really resonate with going
through a transition
and and looking at what we want to do in
our careers
so you might recognize some of these you
miss 100
of the shots you never take some
motivational quotes here as we think
about maybe making a job change
this next one here by warren buffett in
a chronically leaking boat
energy devoted to changing vessels is
more productive than
energy devoted to patching leaks so
sometimes that's maybe when we're
we feel maybe stuck in a job and we just
try to keep trying to fix it but maybe
the what we really need to do is just
change vessels
the next one we have up there we cannot
change
what we are not aware of and once we are
aware we cannot help
but change and that's really that
self-awareness that
comes at the beginning of
realizing that we want to make a change
and how do we make that happen
and the only way to do great work is to
love what you do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
and don't settle
so uh of course steve jobs we have to
have
one up there from him right as we think
about that so
quick look at the agenda and what we're
going to talk about today and welcome to
all of you who are coming feel free to
join in
we are just getting started you haven't
missed anything
and we are going to be talking through
our agenda now
first we're going to look at
self-awareness how do we discover
and leverage those strengths and talents
that we have sometimes we feel like i
talked to a lot of udacity students who
are trying to make a career pivot make a
little bit of a change
and they're really maybe a little stuck
in that self-awareness piece they might
have an idea of what they want to do but
they're not
really sure which direction to take and
which
specific job to be pursuing
so we're going to look at some different
ways that we can get some more insights
into ourselves
how to better understand our strengths
and the talents that we have
then we're going to look at typical
pitfalls that happen
in the job search being aware of these
pitfalls so we can make sure that
it's not happening to you and then next
we'll be looking at some career planning
tools and resources
again we have some special offers for
udacity students and we also have
curated some of the best sources out
there for some
self-assessment tools that don't cost a
fortune as many
do that you might have run into all
right
so with that i am going to pass it to
uh our special guest today and diane if
you want to give any more introduction
about yourself
please do but if you want to go ahead
and i'll leave it here with you
and i'll pass forward the slides along
as you are ready
all right great thanks angela great to
be here great to see we have
uh a good crowd and it's time for all of
you to rocket your career
and we're going to do a quick exercise
here
and we're going to think a little bit
differently about our talents i'd like
you to think a little out of the box and
be creative
and so if you notice here on the screen
we have a number of
images and i'd like you to look at any
one of those images that
resonates with you and think about how
you're like that
image and let me give you an example
so i'm choosing the outlet and the
reason why is because i'm a connector
i like to bring together people and
ideas
and there's some kind of spark there's
some kind of flow of energy
and something gets activated i actually
have a company that connects consultants
with
clients for projects so there's some
sort of like power source and energy
so that's how i'm like that image and
you know when you do this exercise when
you're thinking about it there isn't
any particular one way to think about it
there's no right answer
and maybe there's nothing here on the
screen that resonates with you so if you
don't like any of these images
maybe pick something in your personal
space
i'll just give you a few examples so if
you look at the dice
maybe you're a risk taker or the
stethoscope are you someone who can
listen
kind of below the surface and you kind
of hear the undercurrents
or maybe you're some kind of expert
where you can prescribe
something that's going to make you know
the situation better
you know the ball maybe you're somebody
who brings lightness and you you know
things roll off of you easily so
i'm giving you a few ideas go ahead and
type in the chat
any of these that resonate with you and
you know state the item
and then how you're like that item or
pick something else
yeah you can resonate with more than one
item that's that's absolutely fine
that's great that means the the creative
wheels are turning
and i'll say i'll add diane to your
examples i feel like
i the two that jumped out at me the the
quickest
first was the suitcase may be part of
it's because i
really miss traveling right now and yes
andre please
share your share your discoveries there
in the chat
but the adventure and trying new things
so that that suitcase really resonates
with me and also the rubik's cube
i love having challenges and seeing kind
of things go in order
but then i also like mixing it up and
seeing if i can fix it again i'm a
big puzzle person so
so we've got some responses coming up
yeah someone likes to
see problems from all sides and seek a
happy balance
uh so how are you like the seashell
maybe you can mention that yeah the
rubik's cube they love the challenge in
solving those problems so you're
probably a really good problem solver
uh the rubik's cube they like complex
yet to be systematic
excellent all right so you you get the
idea here
and so this is to help us raise our
self-awareness
so next we're going to talk about your
self-awareness and this is really
important
angela next slide yeah for you to be
able to clearly
articulate your talent you need to be
able to let your prospective employer
know
what you're bringing to the table so
we're going to think a bit differently
and so next one of the ways to think
about our talents
is through metaphors and what's a
metaphor it's a figure of speech
where you look at the essential quality
of something
and it's compared to a powerful image
so think about an astronaut what does an
astronaut do and type that in the chat
an astronaut you know goes where no man
has gone before right
you know i'd say an astronaut is kind of
like a pioneer
of sorts uh an astronaut is an explorer
right
seeks new frontiers absolutely
other thoughts about what astronauts do
don't they collect data
i think they kind of go to the moon
right and they bring back
some kind of artifacts and the other you
know scientists
study them and i actually know someone
yeah uh
explorer scientists data collection
exactly
discovering things in space so there's a
whole element of
of discovery uncharted territory going
into the unknown
yeah exactly surviving and you know this
is kind of a
a scary thing maybe a an astronaut is
somebody who
is a is a big risk taker right so
yeah you guys are getting the idea so
the next slide when one of the sources
of our
talent metaphors is derived from
our childhood aspirations what we wanted
to be
when we grew up so when i was young
i wanted to be a dancer and interesting
you know
i took dance lessons all through grade
school in high school
but you know as i got older my mom was
like you know you're too tall to be a
dancer and you're too big nobody's going
to be able to lift you you know because
i'm like five nine
and um you know not a not a tiny person
and she said the dancers don't make any
money you need to go to college you need
to get an education
and so you know i i actually never
became a real dancer however
if you think about a dancer
metaphorically a dancer
interprets the rhythms and patterns of
the music
and they express them in their own
unique way so
if you like in music to life
i see the rhythms and patterns of what
brings people to life what are their
passions what
what makes them tick what are they
excited about so i'm kind of a talent
detector i cannot help it i'll go to a
social place i'll notice people's kids
i'm like yeah your kid is good in
this this or that you should sign them
up for something
you know i've just got this radar up and
i can't help but
notice what people are good at and
interesting that
my company matches consulting talent
with opportunity so i am using my dancer
talent
all the time and you know a dancer is a
performer right
and so not an accident that i have been
in the field of training
i've been a trainer for many years
myself
and now my company connects consultants
and trainers
with these kinds of different sorts of
projects
and the way that i talk about these
talent metaphors
is that you are born with these gifts
they don't change maybe the form of them
morphs or you know you grow and there's
a new expression of them but this is
kind of what you have been born to do so
if you can identify that that's where
this
essence comes from and that you know you
heard my program is called essential
circles because what we do is we name
your essence and so i've worked with you
know hundreds of different professionals
helping them name and identify
their natural gifts and talents and so
this is uh something that we'll be
talking about a little bit more today
so i'm going to give you some examples
of
different metaphors of a lot of
technical people that i've worked with
uh we did this uh essential circles
program with a company called schneider
electric
and there was like 25 engineers i think
there were 20 of them that were men
five of them that were women all
technology type so of course you know
somebody wanted to be an engineer
and if you think about how
you were when you were less than eight
years old that is when your
essence is kind of pure and it's not
tainted by
you're not going to make any money or
what other people think
those sorts of things and so one of my
clients
was an engineer and he always wanted to
be an engineer when he grew up so it was
kind of
easy for him and some of the things that
he does because i know this might be
some of you he um makes educated
assumptions
he's really good at figuring out how
things work
putting all the pieces together when he
was a kid he just took everything apart
put it back together found ways to
improve lots of things
fixing things and a lot of these
uh folks at schneider electric that i
work with
were also like good at building things
in a physical way so some of them
had those kind of talents and we're
working on like the construction
types of of projects and they didn't
know that they wanted to be an engineer
and you know these talents they express
not only in an intellectual way
but it could be physically it could be
emotionally
you know in in a lot of different ways
interesting with my dancer talent
one of the things that i do is you know
i see rhythms and patterns and i notice
patterns in relationships so i see this
you know all the dysfunction in my
family
you know the patterns of behavior and i
can like predict
exactly what somebody's gonna do and you
know how to avoid it
and that sort of thing so you can see
there's sort of an emotional uh
level of that talent uh another one to
consider
is an athlete and a lot of the folks
that i had worked with
were like uh high performers high
potential employees
and so one of them uh who was you know a
technical person he played soccer
throughout high school now i didn't
really know anything about soccer
but i asked him what position did he
play and he told me
midfielder and i was like well i don't
know what a
midfielder is tell me what does a
midfielder do he said well a midfielder
is a defensive player
right they stop plays but also he did a
lot of
stopping and starting play so he was
also an
offensive player and so a midfielder
surveys the field he knows what's going
on both offensively
and defensively he's really good at
understanding the game
and you know you could say well the game
of business or the game of technology or
you know whatever your
role or function is and
he was really good at taking
strategies and executing them and
implementing them so he was always kind
of shifting gears from strategy to
execution so he was very you know
tactical and visionary multimodal if you
will
and one of the things that was so
interesting
is that he worked in this organization
that was matrixed and they had just
gone through an organization
restructuring and so
the lines of communication and reporting
are really not that clear
and it's kind of difficult to navigate
that but he was so good
being able to leverage the team and
understanding you know who to go to for
what who were his allies
and he was really good at communicating
and focusing
on the you know the team in the
organization for success
definitely he was a competitor so always
focused on
on winning so i've given you a lot of
food for thought here
and so now i'd like for you to think
about
what did you want to be when you grew up
and if you want to type that into the
chats
think back to when you were eight years
old or less
and you know one one of the other people
that i talked with wanted to be
an architect but go ahead and type that
in and
let's see if we can make some sense
thanks to and while we're waiting for
everyone to type in and it's so fun to
see these
you know i think that it's funny that
there's so much
so far in our life we don't think about
that we don't ask ourselves that we
don't
wonder and i think sometimes it's even
the transferable skills that come
through
for me i remember being really young and
wanting to be a newscaster and being
that like
person there with the microphone and and
i never thought much about it i didn't
go into major in anything like that
and then fast forward all these years
and one of my favorite things to do is
teach presentation skills
and i think that's that's my connection
to that childhood
piece that i i find interesting now but
i'll let you now get to some of those
yeah i know we have a lot i i'm seeing a
lot of people who knew they wanted to be
engineers from a young age which is
pretty amazing so let's see what else is
in there and i'll let you
make some comments sure yeah i see here
crazy scientist as a small kid a
mathematician and i know you know a lot
of the things that you use in the
technology world have to do with math
and
logic so you're able to kind of make
sense of that
so i've heard that folks in that field
need to be good in math
uh let's see i have no idea what a
herpetologist is
an olympic games winner uh so yeah you
probably are
kind of got some qualities like the
athlete but you want to be
like the best in the world so you're
probably somebody who's
really very motivated really willing to
work hard
um you know really putting in a lot of
effort not a surprise you're probably
one of those people who's the udacity
student and
has a full-time job uh let's see a
travel
blogger so interesting people who like
to travel are typically
interested in cultures like to
learn and meet new people
and understand kind of the underpinnings
of things
uh let's see here a game developer
that one is kind of interesting you're
probably really good at
um coming up with creative designs
let's see i love finding new things when
i write a code it makes me so excited
uh yeah architecting maybe yep
a musician so musicians is kind of an
interesting one too because
you know you're usually part of uh
you know the symphony or a larger band
right so you probably have a role
you know one of the the images was a
horn
and you know maybe you know when to toot
your own horn when to step
up and also you know when you need to
harmonize with others so you're probably
really good at working with people so i
we could go on here forever but i just
wanted to give you some ideas about this
is the kind of work that we would do
in the in the essential circles program
so angela um i'm going to turn it back
over to you and this is really one of
the first steps that you need to take
in order to know your talents and
strengths and when you know this at a
deep level
you can really be authentic in
presenting your talents
so angela excellent yeah so
so now that you know we're so we want to
take you through as diane's kind of got
that first piece in this essential
circles and thinking about
and that's where we wanted to get you
thinking about you know
what your strengths are what your
natural talents are and how you can
start to see those combined i talked to
a lot of people
through udacity that say you know i
really always wish i had done
x but ended up you know parents pushed
me to do
something else or just ended up like
myself getting into college and thinking
well this is where the best jobs are
going to be so i'm going to be a finance
major i'm going to go into computer
science whatever that is
and then you start looking back and
thinking wait if i'm going to make
a shift why not make a shift in that
direction i really want to go
and and use those natural talents and
use those skills and really
make it make it happen to and make that
change meaningful
as opposed to just taking another step
and not having a purpose in it and
having a little more intention
in our job search so and
we'll talk a little bit more about
diane's program at the end and we'll
have plenty of time for questions
so we want to just jump now into let's
assume now you
you you're at this point where you you
do know what you want to do
but it's about the job search and how to
get there
and the few pitfalls we want to talk
about are first
which is kind of what we just covered
we're unclear of those talents those
skills and strengths
we haven't quite figured out what our
best talent and skills are
to to know what job to target the next
is
the vague goals so we so we have that
maybe that lack of clarity
and then we have a hard time setting a
goal to
to know what we're going after i talk to
a lot of people in coaching sessions who
are struggling with the job search
mainly because they haven't
even identified what exact jobs or a
handful of jobs
or a few companies that they're trying
to target to give them something to aim
for
next is really having a lack of strategy
in the search
the job search can take a lot of time
it's
the more strategy you put behind it and
the more intention
and planning the less you're going to be
sitting in front of your computer just
applying for jobs
we want to open that search up and have
have more focus but have a really good
strategy
and then lastly i think is not seeking
help not finding resources out there
where you can get some help whether it's
a career coach or it's some
insightful assessments that we're going
to share with you today
to help you get that clarity and help
you make a plan
and i want to go through a little bit
you know especially since there are so
many of you on
either have in a position where you you
are looking for a job already or you
want too soon
this is kind of the the stages of change
and transition that we go through and
and that gray area
is is bigger on purpose but if we look
at first there's that ending right
maybe you were laid off maybe you
graduated from college
maybe you decided to change jobs and you
quit maybe you had to move and so you
had to quit your job because you're
moving for a different reason but that
ending
is important to recognize we want to
make sure obviously we don't burn
bridges
but it's also really important to
acknowledge that it's ending recognize
what you'll miss
maybe what you won't miss and and have
that kind of
that ceremonial ending piece that you
know you've kind of
closed that door then there's this next
big stage in the middle which
the neutral zone or we call the
wilderness and this is where
the navigation gets tough right this is
where you're in the middle of the job
search
you're on that journey you still might
be
sad or grieving some things you left
behind that you had to leave behind a
job you liked
a place you lived i know for me having
moved
a lot around a lot and having to change
jobs
it was always that wilderness stage i
found myself in a lot
and we need to find ways to navigate
through that because it's really easy to
maybe fall back
into that that ending feeling where
we're kind of in that grief stage we
want to make sure we're getting through
that
understanding as you see the pictures
there's going to be days where it feels
icky and there's a cloud above us but
we're going to find ways to get through
that wilderness
wilderness and then next to say that uh
just a comment about the wilderness it
you know it's it's wider because
sometimes that can be a longer period of
time
and that's where a lot of the creativity
starts to
formulate because there's some kind of
openness there
and then there's a need right yeah
absolutely and finding that and letting
yourself have some
hopefully time to self-discover and and
make some strategic moves
to make that change be so that you're
you look like that little icon at the
end in the new beginning where you're
stepping into that new job
you're celebrating that win and you
really have that growth mindset to go on
to the next
uh step in your career so
let's see where where kind of some of
you are feeling right now
and if you go up to the annotations you
can click
either a star not sure if you all have i
think
most of you could annotate it looked
like earlier so if you click on annotate
and give me a few options first yeah
view options and then
pick a stamp draw a line
show me where you think you might be
right now
yeah somebody one person in the neutral
zone and i know we have like 30 people
on so yeah
see a lot more there we go and if and if
you're not able to
get on the screen for whatever reason
feel free to chat in
and understand every stage is important
good or bad
you know i think about the endings even
you know i think a lot about
this year especially where so many young
people graduated from high school or
college and they didn't get that
graduation
which you can kind of think oh is that a
big deal well it is kind of a big deal
there's a reason we have ceremonies to
to end something even if it was
something great
that we might be uh excited to move on
but we still
need to recognize that that end is there
so it's really important to celebrate it
it's okay to have a little grief it's
okay to feel sad sometimes
the key is we just don't want to be
stuck in that end too long
and we don't want to be in the neutral
zone for an excessive amount of time
that we feel lost
that we feel lost for too long because
part of that wilderness is a
exciting exploration and but there are
parts of it that that do feel a little
gloomy and sad we want to make sure
we're
navigating our way through there yeah it
looks like most people
are in the neutral zone and i think that
is probably just a common theme
across people who are employed or
unemployed because
so much change is going on and so much
uncertainty is happening
that many people even if they have a job
feel like they're in the neutral zone
because they don't know what to expect
and how things are going to change and
if they're going to have a job
yeah yeah that's exactly right and i
think that
we can feel that if we i've talked to a
lot of people recently who had
maybe pre-covered had thought about
changing jobs and then covet hit and it
was kind of like
okay i'll just stay where i am right now
but they're still feeling uncertainty
um maybe even if they have job security
that's not where they want to be they
want to move on
i know with a lot of udacity students as
you learn these new skills and you're
upskilling
the ideas for a lot of people is you're
ready to make that next jump so you've
kind of finished that nanodegree you're
feeling really excited about it
but maybe the job market's not where you
want it to be where
most of us want it to be but there are
still jobs out there and we want to help
you navigate that
um yeah sarah says i want to move on but
yeah
is the covet is a big factor as we all
know
so thanks for sharing those stages and
keep that in mind and
and actually while we as we finish up
here i've got a great podcast
that is it's not too long i listened to
recently and it talked a lot about these
transitions and i'll share that with you
if you're interested
okay so how do we avoid the pitfalls we
want to make sure you're growing your
self-awareness making sure that we
we know what we're after we have those
straight that strength and skills
inventory all ready to go beginning with
the end in mind
knowing where we're trying to get to
where is it where is that
that new beginning what do we want that
to look like what do we want it to
visualize it to be what do we
you know name it what's the job title
make a vision board whatever kind of
person you are
if is it a spreadsheet showing you know
uh
bullet points of what it is you want
that next job to look like
and again really having a career
strategy
that you know what that next step is
going to be
doesn't mean that you have to have like
my ultimate
you know job in 10 years is gonna look
like this it's okay if you don't know
that
but know something shoot shoot for
something out there
so that you know you're making progress
along the way
and then tap into unique resources that
are available to you
if you're still udacity student there's
a lot of resources as you know in the
career portal
if you're alumni and you don't have
access to that anymore we still have
some resources to share with you today
because i know there's so much out there
it can get overwhelming
so we've tried to curate you a little
list
i really like this quote by stephen
covey
about thinking about the end in mind and
thinking what that goal is
to begin with the end in mind means to
start with a clear understanding of your
destination
knowing where you're going what does
that job look like it means to know
where you're going
so that you better understand where you
are now and all those steps you're
taking
are giving you in the right direction
so keeping that quote in mind as you
think about
setting those goals and and knowing what
those target roles are
so as you start to identify that target
role where you're headed
look at your strengths keep clarifying
that goal
research job descriptions and start you
know i talk to a lot of people that say
you know
if you say well give me an idea of the
job you're looking for and i'm not
and they'll say i'm not sure yet i'm
just applying like all over the place
i want to get that focus and start
talking to people
that have the job you want or you think
you want if you know
if you've thought okay i'm going to take
this digital marketing course
and i've never spoken to anyone in
digital marketing you need to start
having those conversations start getting
that first hand knowledge
follow blogs influencers and talk to
people
and i'll just say you know one of the
things that people love to do
is give advice and you know you could
ask them you know what is the day in the
life of a digital marketer like and
people love to talk about themselves
that's their favorite subject
and if you ask them for you know their
input
and how did they get where they're going
they'll be happy to talk to you
yeah i think that's so true and i think
that there's different things
depending on where you are kind of in
your life and what
what you can share a lot of you have
great experience that you could be
offering them advice as well
so always think that it can always be a
two-way conversation
if you're young and you feel like i'm
kind of right out of school i really
don't feel like i have that much to
offer
well that's even a bigger reason for
people to like to help you right they
always like to help the young student
who's kind of just getting started
so you know really think about people to
reach out to and as as part of our
program we talk a lot about
that those crucial connections and and
figuring out how to strategically reach
out to people
not just reaching out to people to say
hey are you guys hiring we want to go
deeper than that
so how do you create this strategy and
and again there's so many resources and
and there's a lot of great webinars
where we go into a lot more detail on
setting those goals and that you can
look out for on the udacity youtube site
but what we want to do is show you what
we've developed real quick on
how to create a strategic job search
plan
and really making sure again that has a
lot of intention
so that your search ends up being way
more efficient
i know a lot of people that start the
job search again kind of like
you know the darts are all just going
all over in this like
big mass of uh online
job uh you know online jobs that they're
applying for
and nothing's hitting because it's just
way too spread out and there's no plan
when we get together we start coaching
they go through a program that's much
more strategic they actually feel like
they spend a lot more time
applying and they see the progress
because it has
real strategy
so the program that so we're going gonna
talk so there's two programs we're
really talking about today one is the
career essentials or career circles
sorry
um that we talk about really discovering
it as
what you want and and knowing those
talents and skills
then once you have an idea a better idea
of
the job you're going for and you're
starting on the search
we've created up next which is an
basically an online class
with a coach online with you that leads
you through the whole
job search so the it's a four
it's designed to go over about four
weeks and there's four levels so that
first level
kind of takes on from the career
essentials creating your vision and
mindset
helping you get all the tools you need
getting you a journal
getting organized in that next level
getting your resume
your cover letter linkedin all put
together
moving into that network again those
crucial connections
and helping people have a real strategy
on reaching out to people and then
finally excelling in the interview
so the program is it's self-paced
there's always a coach
on the platform that gives you written
feedback throughout
and then when you finish you kind of
should have most people start
interviewing through the whole process
but it's giving you all the tools you
need and really
i like to say holding your hand through
the job search not that anyone really
really needs their hand held
but when we think of ourselves in the
wilderness and that in that neutral zone
right it's kind of nice to say
you know what you don't have to figure
this out i'm going to help you through
it
and that's really the purpose of this
program
up next so what i really like about it
is that everything is in one place
you know when you're in a job search and
you're talking to employers and you're
talking to networking contacts and
you're doing research there's a lot of
information and it's hard to stay
organized and
follow up in a timely manner angela has
created this really great
tool for keeping you organized and
not only do you have someone to get
feedback
as she mentioned you get a coach but you
can go through it with
other people in a community so other
people who are
in job search so there is a social
aspect to it
and you can not only get feedback from
your coach but get feedback from other
people who are also in job search if you
want to test out your elevator pitch
those sorts of things so there's uh it's
just great not to be alone
when you're going through job search it
can be very isolating and sometimes
you know your energy and confidence
level waivers
and being involved with other people can
help that kind of be more stable
yeah i think so and i think the job
search is low
can be very lonely as it is and then put
covet on top of everything
where you're not even getting to to get
in like if you
trying to like meet up with those
crucial connections everything's being
virtual so
really finding ways to have more
community and reach out to people
so like she said that we have cohorts
that go through as well
you can sign up for this on your own and
do it on your own but you could also
join we're going to start a udacity
cohort so that there's a lot of people
in tech
kind of in the same community that can
bounce ideas off of each other
network with each other one of my uh and
i'm like diane in terms of connecting
people i love when
i've been able to even connect udacity
students with each other and i know
there was i had
two people and they were from they were
both from italy but living in france and
kind of in the same industry one had
just gotten a job
maybe six months before and the other
person was looking for something really
similar and they ended up
connecting having coffee together and it
was great like so
and that person ended up helping the
second person get a job and i i love
when those kinds of things happen so
and that's all because they opened up
and talked to someone and shared what
was going on with them and what they
were looking for
so maybe at this point uh what i'll do
is i want to show you guys
show you all the offer that we have for
udacity students and alumni
and then we'll open it up to questions
and then we have a few other resources
that we want to share
that are available out there that we
think we both really like and think are
super useful
so this this is the offer that we have
for udacity students and alumni right
now
and so essential circles again is
diane's program that is all about
figuring out those strengths
understanding your natural gifts and
talents and i'll let her talk about that
a little more
so normally it's a 1500 14.99 and
we're offering it for 7.99 and then
the up next career program is normally
4.99 and we have that for udacity
students and alumni for 199.
i will post those links in the chat as
well
but at this time i think oh and we've
got the first 10 people who register
will be getting
a free coaching session with either
myself diane or one of our colleagues
so at this stage why don't we open it up
diane maybe you can talk a little bit
more about your program i think
yeah we could use a little more detail
and then we can open it up for
questions great thank you so you guys so
the essentials
the essential circles program has five
steps so the first one i call talent
illumination and that's where we're
shedding light on your talents and we
actually give you a talent identity
profile you go through a conversational
assessment process
and we'll talk about those childhood
dreams and things like that
and then the next step is called talent
alignment how is what you have done in
the past or what you're doing now
aligned with your talent profile
and then the next step is talent
articulation
so are you able to now take those
talents that you have
clarity about and be able to give
examples and talk about it in a very
authentic way
and so when you're coming from this
place of you know your
your childhood it is natural to you a
lot of times when you're
in the job search or you're talking with
people for interviews or networking
is some kind of awkwardness this gives
you this
just naturally able to be you if you
will
and then the last one i call talent
embodyment and this is where we focus on
kind of the mind you know the appearance
and and the the way you speak and so
you're getting all of those in alignment
so
you know maybe you want to be some kind
of artist but you're coming to the
interview and you're like in a
three-piece suit you know
that isn't an alignment for what an
artist would do or the opposite you know
it could be that you
you know have pink hair or something and
you're trying to be in a very corporate
environment and maybe that's not kind of
the culture
so we try to get all of that in
alignment and then the fifth step is
now you take all of that and you go to
up next
armed with your strategy and all of this
great information
so angelina if you want to talk anymore
yeah so
yeah so i thought let's open it up for
questions if anyone has questions at
this point
please feel free to unmute or if you're
not if you want to
ask your question in the chat that's
okay too well i'm looking there as well
i think a couple questions i think other
people had asked me
previously that i thought we'd start
with can you talk a little bit about if
someone does want to discover
if they want to go through essential
circles can you tell us like about
how long does that take someone um
i'd say you could probably complete it
within
um a month or so it depends on
you know how motivated you are how much
time you have but it could certainly be
done
in a longer period of time or it could
be done in a shorter period of time
i'd say that a lot of it is reflective
work so
you need to have some time and some
space to kind of be quiet
let things sort of surface and you don't
want to rush it you know you just
you can't speed up the process it takes
as long as it's going to take and
everybody is a little bit different but
i'd say you know we'd have
like one coaching session a week with
some
um you know homework assignments very
similar to angela's program where
it's all uh in this experiential
platform
so there'll be some visualization
activity there's some drawing
it's a really very different way of
approaching your talents
great and can you tell us a little bit
about
like the is there a typical age or
or stage of career that that you work
with people or
maybe give us some examples on how it's
helped people at different stages or
ages of their life
sure yeah so um the work that we did
with
um corporations is folks who are sort of
early career and so i'd say that's maybe
the
you know like first five to ten years
something like that
we actually do have programs for um we
call it career essentials
uh one where uh you have someone maybe
who
is like a director and they're being
promoted to a vice president or to a new
level
so there's uh various different versions
of it
so you can really be at any stage of
your career but i'd say
it's when you want to make a change when
you want to maybe go to the next level
of your career no matter where you are
you can certainly do it if you're brand
new out of school but you don't have as
many experiences
to kind of fall back on to know if it's
aligned or not so you'd have to
go with things that um you know in your
college days or
in high school great yeah and i think
another thing that i
one another challenge that i see people
have is when they want to
when they're trying to pivot right from
from what maybe even one area of tech
into another area from engineering
more into uh data science or they're
making some type of shift i think having
a little more insight and it kind of it
helps bring out like
those transferable skills that
oftentimes people will say
there's nothing i've done in my past
that has anything to do with what i'm
trying to do now and i always challenge
them to say i really believe there's
something
right there's always some things that
you've done is if you start looking
through job descriptions of what you
want to do next
and really have a strong sense of your
your talents your gifts your strengths
there's going to be some alignment
and of those skills that you can bring
with you can't wake up as like a whole
different person and plop into a job you
bring with you a lot of
experience a lot of talent a lot of
strengths that you just need to uncover
so that you're ready to to a to talk
about it in the interview right to be
able to kind of sell that
and then believe in it yourself yeah
absolutely i think it's pretty rare that
someone hasn't done anything that's
related to their talents
the thing is that you're not aware of it
you know when you
have natural gifts and talents things
come very easily to you and because of
that
you don't notice that you're really good
at it because maybe you just
naturally do it you can't help it but
other people will notice that
and you probably have been involved in
some kind of you know volunteering or
clubs or various things throughout your
life
that maybe you were actually using those
talents
in a big way and so that's kind of what
we try to tap into
as angela said is those transferable
skills and when you have
the stories and the examples and you
want to make that career change you know
from one field to another
it becomes very credible so that's that
that's really
a big value that you get is you kind of
get to draw upon the past and show how
it applies to the present
and then people will believe that you
can do that job that you've never done
before
in that new field i love it
absolutely so who has a question who
would like to unmute and ask a question
let's open it up and see if we've got a
few of you want to speak with us today
i was just curious i didn't understand
um andreas
comment here he said in his case clients
always
ask him for what i like less because
that's where i have more experience
oh okay so it's difficult to escape that
so people are asking you about the
things that you've done before
but that's not what you want to do is
that right or can you can you explain
that a little bit more
andre can you unmute and and give us a
little insight there
maybe he's not here she's not able to
unmute i think
i have a feeling what i've what i've
heard other people say is
they have clients that they want them to
do a certain oh he said one second
please sorry
uh we'll see if he can unmute um a lot
of times working as
consultants or or someone sees your your
resume or your linkedin says oh i want
to hire you to do x
but you're really not wanting even
though you know you're good at it
it's what you don't love to do and
you're really trying to make that shift
so you keep getting pulled back into
maybe that
piece of your experience that you just
want to hide for a while and go do
something else
yeah yeah so that pieces i think i think
andre is there now
yeah yeah that's the thing that um
i have some experience on web
development and i
i spent like 10 years doing that but
actually i'm more
interested on other stuff artificial
intelligence and so on and
although i studied that things those
things
yeah i didn't had so much experience on
that area so
people continue hiring me for these
other things that i did before
yeah yeah so i think that you know
that's where something like the
essential circles could help you
with repositioning because there's
probably talents that
you're using in web development and i'm
not saying
skills i'm saying talents and that's a
little bit different
and how can you position yourself in
your resume
and your linkedin profile to talk about
your talents
which can be applied in many ways you
know like i talk about the dancer
right the dancer i can be a one-on-one
coach i'm an entrepreneur
i interpret the rhythms and patterns of
what's going on in the marketplace and
coming up with services to
offer so there's a lot of different ways
to apply
the dancer talent and the same thing
that you could do with
whatever your talents are but if it's in
that traditional
and you have this kind of chronological
resume or way of presenting yourself
of course that's what people are going
to see and notice so how do you begin
to shift that and to talk about where
you're coming from in terms of talents
as with i'm sure with web development
there's some things that you could apply
to artificial intelligence right
are there some things or anything come
to mind
you can go ahead and unmute again
maybe he's digesting that yeah okay
any other questions we still have a few
minutes
okay we've got one i'll read this one
out loud to make sure everyone sees it
regarding network networking i think
it's really important especially if
you're looking to
change careers i've been connecting with
people on linkedin
asking them about their role their
company but their responses haven't been
great
i've received two to three responses so
how does one go about improving
networking
yeah you know that is uh and i if you've
gotten two to three responses you should
just celebrate those wins first of all
because
i always tell people when you're when
you're the one reaching out first of all
it's
to you it's something really important
but to someone who's working and busy
and going about their day it be
sometimes it's not the most response
it's not the most
important thing on their list right so
one of the most important things i
always tell people when they're when
you're kind of cold messaging and
reaching out
find that one thread with that person
you have in common and let them know
that
oh i see we're both udacity students oh
oh i
noticed we both went to the same
university hey i see we both worked for
bank of america at some point
whatever it is to give them that
commonality that common thread that
is the reason you want to talk to them
gives them a little bit of the the
reason or the guilt
to think oh i should i should really i
should reach out and talk to diane you
know we i realized we both went to the
same school
whatever it is so that they feel a
little more obliged to talk to you it
also makes it feel more legitimate
i think there's now a lot of people i
feel like
every day i have however many
requests on linkedin and people asking
but they're really just trying to get
your business
so they're the kind of selling or
marketing to you so
it's you want to not that there's
anything wrong with someone
selling or marketing to you but if
you're truly networking let me
you want people to know that you want to
know like hey i'm really trying to learn
let them know if you've just graduated
let them know that if you've just
changed jobs
people want to help people who are
looking for jobs and generally speaking
in life i think
most people would love to help someone
find a job if they can
or at least give them some insight into
some information they have that might
help you as you're on your job search
yeah and i think when you're networking
you want to try to ask
them something that they would be
willing to say yes to
or want to say yes to so do you have any
open jobs is probably
a no right or they don't know so what
could you
ask them that they would want to do
so you know if you are interested in
something that they're working on or
you're interested in working
on artificial intelligence and you want
to get advice based on where you are now
and how to uh and you want to talk to
people in those roles because this is
what you're interested in
and you'd like to get their advice
people is like
using the word advice people love to
give advice
you know like find a way to stroke them
stroke their ego if you will and
you'll find that more people would be
willing to do that but the
asking the right questions i think is
really important
in networking and maybe not starting
with asking about a job
starting with asking about what you're
passionate about and what you're
interested in
and that's something that you know when
you go through these
um programs it helps you to identify
those things and you have something to
really connect with somebody about like
there's a spark there's an
energy in that conversation that's what
you want to have happen
and then you know they become a
networking contact not just somebody
who's helping you now
but maybe you build a relationship and
they that's kind of
the goal of networking right is to have
this uh
safety this security net not just now
for in the future and
i know angela teaches this about you
know make it reciprocal
what can you do for them so that there's
a two-way street there
great well i know we're getting close to
the end of our time so i did want to
share
a one more a few more pieces of uh
some resources for you to know about so
these are the two that diane and i have
created
that we're offering the special on
they'll be available until the end of
november
so again you can join in anytime the
that link that says
up next for udacity will take you to
where we're going to have a udacity
cohort all
in the in the same kind of classroom
very similar to like you do at udacity
but it's a class all about the job
search
if you would prefer to do it on your own
and not in a cohort you can contact me
and we'll make sure that we can get you
on to that as well uh and sarah yes we
can share the presentation it will be
on the udacity youtube channel and i can
get that channel for you in just a
second
and i'll post it in there where you can
find all of the career coaching
webinars lastly we'll go through just a
couple other i think fun resources that
are
very affordable and i think ones that
are often you find on the market not so
affordable
and so diane and i have kind of curated
some some different ones that we really
like
some of these you might have done at
work in the past
and you can let us all know what you
think of it disc i really like it talks
it's a very
i think simple is not really the right
word but it's very concise it helps you
understand your communication style at
work
if you're having communication
issues or if you felt like you maybe
have had some challenges in the past or
you're getting ready to work for a new
manager that has a different style i
think disc is really good for
understanding
your communication style um
diane maybe i so i can go on to my uh
computer here and look for those other
two sources could you talk a little bit
about the strengths finder in the
enneagram
yeah so the strength finder there's um
a tool here and this is the one to the
to the book correct
or is this the online test yeah that
link gets you to the book and then you
get the code
where you can then yeah so so there are
34 strengths
and um you can take a test that gives
you your top five
and when i work with the essential
circles we only identify your top five
because those are what you
want to focus on if you can find a job
where you're using all your strengths
you're going to be a happy camper
and then the enneagram gets at your
motivators
and it actually works really well with
the essential circles it aligns with
your
childhood patterns if you will and so
there are two tests there when you go on
the link this one's only uh twelve
dollars
and you wanna take the ready test
r-h-e-i-e-t-i
and so that one will get you information
kind of
uh on your whole self it isn't just work
it's
you as a whole person so that's kind of
a neat thing because it looks at you
more broadly
uh someone asked about a podcast that
you mentioned angela they were yeah
yeah i'm gonna put that in now so it's
the reboot podcast it's the reboot
extras number 10
leading through transitions so
uh what did all the podcasts say at the
end you can find that wherever you
listen to your
podcast i'm pretty sure mine was on
spotify
but i'm sure it's on all the yeah they
all seem to be everywhere now
um so it's leading through transitions
so i'll send that and then i need to
stop sharing to go get the other link
for you all
so one thing i'll do really quick here
is i'll just
put all of these links
in the chat and while i'm getting the
youtube channel so that you all have
that
handy is there anything else anyone want
to ask
any questions open it up anything
on your mind related or not
and i will go ahead at this point and
stop recording so we have a nice
clear end to our recording so thanks
those of you who are listening now
in the recorded version thanks for
listening and
i will put up our email addresses in
case there's someone that wants to
contact us directly and i will stop
recording
now and then i will stop sharing and get
the youtube
channel so everyone can see this later
and it again if you're on live right now
feel free to
mute yourself and ask a question we'll
be here for a couple minutes